gleich in den ersten momenten da kam es
nämlich zu der frage würde armin laschet
der ja derzeit massiv zurück liegt in
den umfragen eigentlich auch als
vizekanzler in die regierung gehen und
wie er darauf reagiert hat das wollen
wir uns einmal kurz anschauen
sind nicht bei regierungsbildungen wir
sind beim berge um den richtigen weg
schon sagen was steht jetzt an wir
werden auf keinen fall mit einigen
kollegen auf keinen fall mit der fdp
koalieren wir werden mit denen nicht mal
reden wenn wir nicht kooperieren und
demokraten untereinander müssen nach der
wahl reden wir kämpfen um platz eins
armin laschet hat ganz bewusst gesagt er
möchte diese frage nicht beantworten
thomas was sagt dass ihn wenn er nicht
klar sagen wir inhaltlich gehen nicht in
die koalition als vizekanzler weil ich
ja kanzler werden will also ich frag ich
finde die frage war sehr legitim denn
wir alle wissen ja dass es zu einem mehr
oder weniger bunten koalition kommen
muss wenn die die zahlen so sind wie man
sie im moment annimmt und wir gehen
davon aus dass es so sein wird hielt die
frage für legitim und sein sein
ausweichen habe ich nicht nachvollziehen
können es ist doch genauso wenn ich
einer frau einen heiratsantrag machen
dann sage ich wie sieht es mit dem
kinderwunsch aus und wenn mir jemand
sagt ja jetzt musste doch erstmal darum
nicht kümmern dass diese frau die ich
liebte ich werde nicht sagen mir geht es
jetzt erst einmal darum dass ich sie zum
traualtar führen mir geht es jetzt erst
einmal darum dass ich ihr den ring an
streife und ich will wissen konkret was
passiert dann also wenn ich eine ehe
eingehen muss ich meiner frau und allen
die es angeht erklären was ich dann
plane wie es also weiter geht und das
sind diese antwort ausgewichen ist halte
ich für und nachvollziehbar als auch für
falsch und nena er hätte doch einfach
ganz klar sagen können nein mach ich
nicht weil ich werde der bundeskanzler
oder hätte sagen müssen ich meine in dem
moment erwartete man ja stärke man will
ja einen wandel haben er sagt das will
ich und nur das aber was ich auch ganz
spannend in der armin laschet hat ja
schon aus dem kleinen moment der
schwäche schon vorher als er darauf
hingewiesen hat dass nicht immer nur der
mit den meisten stimmen kanzler wird das
war natürlich war das stimmt fdp hat ist
auch schon mal gemacht dass damals 1976
aber er muss jetzt sagen ich krieg alle
stimmen und nicht darauf hinweisen sagen
na ja auch wenn ich nicht alle stimmen
kriege ist es auch möglich dass die
koalition anders gefunden werden und
deswegen moment der schwäche für angela
stellt heute abend für unsere zuschauer
man sieht es nina schenk an 1976 ist
nicht deine erinnerung sondern das hast
du logischerweise nachgelesen klaus
hätte armin laschet dann nicht einfach
klar und hart zuschlagen müssen und
sagen wirst niemals weil ich vizekanzler
unter olaf scholz und mehr noch er sagen
können die frage stellt sich für mich
gar nicht denn wir werden die stärkste
partei die stärkste fraktion und ich
werde bundestag und dann kann olaf
scholz sich mit der frage befassen was
er dann mit dem wahlergebnis macht ich
habe aber eine das hat mich heute
während des ganzen lautenschlager
brechen musste ich ganz kurz
unterbrechen und entspannt für unsere
zuschauer wir warten jetzt auf die
ergebnisse der blitzumfrage die jetzt
jede sekunde hier reinkommt das wird
natürlich etwas und da ist sie armin
laschet
18 am sympathischsten 35 am
kompetentesten
dass ein hochspannender ergebnisse von
unseren kollegen von der ard wir sehen
armin laschet hat bei diesen
umfragen vergleich kanzlerkandidaten
bisher dramatisch verloren sowohl bei
einem sympathischen als auch bei am
kompetentesten
liegt er jeweils auf dem erst auf dem
dritten und dann auf dem zweiten platz
zwei ein kompetentes kompetent als
annalena baerbock wir sehen es hier und
schauen gleich noch rein was es da an
weiteren ergebnissen gibt bei den
kollegen von anne will was erklären wir
unseren zuschauern kurz dieses trio
heute abend ist in der ard gelaufen und
bei den kollegen von anne will wird
jetzt die blitz befragung nach den nach
diesem 3 dort präsentiert wir gehen
gleich nochmal rein wenn es darum geht
wer hat bei diesem trio geworden auch
diese zeigen dieses geben klaus ich
hatte dich unterbrochen angela schmidt
hätte zuschlagen müssen ja also die
zahlen sind natürlich dramatisch ich
habe einfach die ganze zeit als ich mir
das angeguckt hat mich ein gefühl
beschlichen dass eine
regierungskoalition von der überhaupt
nicht geredet wird vielleicht am ende
die ist die wieder kommt und das ist die
große koalition also überlegt euch doch
das mal wir reden jetzt ständig in
diesen dreier bündnissen es gibt aber
ein zweierbündnis das recht vielleicht
26 und 24 sind für 50 oder man glaubt
also das bedeutet ich glaube das lasche
bereits auch die variante in betracht
zieht der juniorpartner der spd in einer
großen koalition zu sein und dann sagen
kann wir hatten einen verrückten
wahlkampf wir haben gekämpft bis zum
schluss und es ist mir noch gelungen die
cdu in der regierung zu halten
sensationell das könnte doch auch der
grund sein warum man da nicht so auf
wandelt wie mir saß und oder wird wieder
dieses offensichtlich ist dass der
wunsch der bürgerinnen und bürger in den
willen der bürger gestalten den
wählerwillen wäre genau das ist das was
ich überhaupt vermisse in diesem
gesamten wahlkampf ich habe ja einige in
amerika miterlebte haben männer mit mid
mid mid mid vor zorn geschwollenem hans
behauptet ich werde wohl beliebtesten
doch das country- und mit dieser
prämisse marschieren die 1 ich habe bei
keinem dieser drei menschen die
leidenschaft erlebt die ich mir wünsche
von meinen zukünftigen kanzler
schrägstrich kanzlerin
[Musik]